we have mentioned many times this
morning how the Columbia faculty are
critical to the success of our students
there is no better example of this than
our valedictorian Maxwell Burt Alero
Maxwell who hails from the Bay Area will
tell you himself about his own
challenging path to GS but I want to add
on Maxwell's behalf how grateful he is
to one particular faculty member who has
been an incredible mentor to him when
Professor Daphna shoham II of the
Department of Psychology received the
prestigious lend fest teaching award
this fall she chose Maxwell to be the
student who would speak about her as a
teacher and mentor professor sho Hama he
said helped me see that thoughtful
neuroscience research can tell us what
it means to be human
and make a genuine difference
she helped me develop the analytic
skills required to do that type of
neuroscience research and helped foster
a confidence in my intellectual
abilities that I lacked Maxwell
completed his degree work requirements
in December and professor shoham I
offered him the opportunity to do
research with her during the spring
semester while he waited to hear back
from PhD programs it was very excited by
the opportunity but he writes what
brought tears to my eyes as I read her
email in Avery library is that she said
she wanted me to work with her because I
think like a scientist
after spending my adolescence not being
intellectually respected to have someone
not only praised my work but also
praised the way I think was overwhelming
this tribute to Professor Daphna Shoham
I could I am sure be repeated by many of
you about your own faculty Mentors
and I'm sure that you will see the
powerful result of this transformative
engagement between student and mentor in
our valedictorian and his words
Max Weber Calero is not only a brilliant
scientist but a passionate humanist
a man of integrity and compassion I hope
he said that one day I can do what
Daphna did for me for someone else
Max Weber talero graduates with a double
major in honors in psychology and
philosophy higher than in a average
summa laude a Phi Beta Kappa and a
member of the GS Honor Society he is the
only graduating senior in the country to
be accepted to work towards his PhD in
the research laboratory of the eminent
cognitive neuroscience at the University
of California Berkeley professor Marc
despedido
it is a privilege for me to present to
you the valedictorian of the class of
Maxwell Bertil era before I want to
before I start I just want to thank Tina
on for those kind words everything he's
done for me and for general studies as a
program if you've ever come into contact
with him even through an email I'm sure
you know that he's a lovely human being
so round of applause for Dean on
president Bollinger Provost cotesworth
executive vice president Dirk's general
Casey Dean on families friends and
fellow graduates think back to what you
were doing nine years ago give you a
second
none of the memories we just conjured up
forecast us graduating from Columbia
today nine years ago I was so depressed
and anxious that I could barely function
and I groaned disgusted with high school
both socially and academically I pleaded
with my high school deans to let me take
some time off but they threatened that
I'd be expelled if I was not at school
the next day and then I would never get
into a good college I would never get a
good job I would never be happy I would
be labeled hyperactive undisciplined /
emotional the next day I drove to school
but every time I reached for the door
handle
I was paralyzed just completely overcome
with tears I could not get out of my car
there was so much pressure to fit a mold
I just did not fit and continuing to try
to shove myself into that mold was
hopeless so I grabbed on to the only
thing I enjoyed doing at the time a
sport called motocross which is racing
dirt bikes around tracks composed of
hills turns jumps and bumps when I was
floating 90 feet through the air with my
heart a hummingbird my anxiety and
depression could not touch me so well my
friends finished high school
I moved to the Southern California
desert which is the epicenter of the
sport in order to pursue a career racing
dirt bikes I spent five years of my life
completely dedicated to making a living
racing I got beat a lot I broke a lot of
bones
but I learned that completely dedicating
myself to something I am passionate
about and letting it consume me makes me
happy but one can't race motocross
forever
and despite my somewhat troubled
academic history I always had a passion
for learning so my mom suggested I take
just one class I started studying
philosophy at Orange Coast Community
College I was terrified but I applied
what I had learned from racing to
academics
I studied what I was passionate about
and I let it consume me and it worked
the next thing I knew I was a Columbia
student and now I'm standing up here all
of our convoluted complicated and messy
paths to this moment are far from
recommended usually if you don't think
yeah usually if you don't fit the norm
if you deviate even once from the
traditional path it's expected that you
won't be successful you certainly won't
end up here but we made it here because
jesus knows that progress most often
results from deviations from the norm
and the world needs more educated people
who are not afraid to deviate from the
norm
as a result of this opportunity and our
hard work we are some of the most
educated rule breakers in the world as
Noam Chomsky says opportunity confers
responsibility with our remarkable past
and our amazing education comes an even
greater responsibility we came here not
afraid to think differently and we have
to continue to think differently to
blaze new paths and really embody the
values the GS saw in us when they
invited us here but we also have to use
the skill that is the defining value of
our liberal arts education the ability
to control the way we think we now have
the ability to choose to think
rationally and logically even when it
leads us to a result that seems grimmer
than the results our intuitions deliver
as my symbolic logic professor Achille
Varzi explained learning to use logic
frees one's mind from being bound by
one's limited intuitions my struggles
with mental disease my studies of
philosophy and the brain and my newfound
ability to use reason and logic instead
of intuition have led me to some
counterintuitive and unconventional
insights concerning human freedom we all
intuitively feel as if we freely will
our thoughts and our actions and we
judge others actions as freely willed
however this intuitive belief is flawed
fighting depression sorry fighting
depression taught me that there are
limits to our freedom
I couldn't simply wilmore serotonin in
my brain I couldn't just decide to be
happy and have it happen but people
judged me as if I could my high school
attributed my troubles to
character flaws not chemical imbalances
had an organ other than my brain been
affected I certainly would have been
given time off to recover my
philosophical and scientific studies
here have taught me that I am not an
entity that is separate from and
controls the workings of my brain I am
what my brain does during my Depression
I wasn't freely controlling the storm of
activity in my brain I wasn't lost in
that storm
I was the storm as Einstein explains
human beings in their thinking feeling
and acting are not free agents but are
as causally bound as the stars are in
their motion we are all forced screaming
into this world with random genetics set
upon a path we didn't even choose and
for every choice we make we can in
theory trace a causal chain back to
one's genetics and the path one was
placed on at conception
it's an illusion that a person what we
each call eye is a separate entity that
can alter this causal chain independent
of the chain itself we can't be an
uncaused cause of our behavior we simply
perceive our thoughts and our behavior
as such when the causes of them are
obscure to us so I'm not claiming that
we're not in control of our decisions of
the way in which we think or our actions
and I'm not saying that our lives are
predetermined that we are fated and we
can just sit back and the same events
will occur no matter what effort we put
in or the decisions we make I didn't
show up to Colombian say well I have a
personal history that interacts well
with my genetics so I can just sit back
relax and watch the perfect grades flow
in trust me that's not how it happened
I had to try it stream ly hard
but while I put in that effort my
ability to do so to be motivated to not
fall back into depression were not
things I earned on my own had I been
born with different genetics to a
different family or even had different
events occur in my life I could have
failed miserably as Charles Darwin
explains this view should teach one
profound humility one deserves no credit
for anything nor ought one to blame
others this does not mean that sometimes
I don't feel a little tiny bit
self-important given my accomplishments
or blame others for their actions but I
can choose to use reason and logic to
override those flawed intuitions and
emotions realizing that we are not
completely free is scary but as Bertrand
Russell says even though the open
windows of science make us shiver after
the comfortable indoor warmth of
traditional humanizing myths that fresh
air brings bigger and the great spaces
of science have a grander all their own
the scientific view of human freedom
leads us down a more pragmatic and
empathetic path then does the myth of
free will as it views the brain as
another organ that can break but also
that can be fixed and promotes empathy
not blame towards the person who is
suffering I have let neuroscience and
philosophy
consume me and now I perceive everything
including human freedom differently than
I did before I have loved this process
and I hope that my career as a scientist
allows me to constantly see things
differently than I did the day before
both inside and outside of the lab and
that I can discuss what I see with
others in hopes of making the world a
tiny bit better to me that is a source
of happiness that feeds off its
growing stronger every single day this
has been my development as a person
while your development was certainly
different in content and conclusions it
was not different in methodology and
opportunity and we all share the same
responsibilities we all have a logical
free and fearless intellect combined
with a unique perspective given our past
from this opportunity flows the
responsibility not to waste it to use it
to make the world a tiny bit better
it is unimaginably hard to do this to
stay actively conscious and logical
really thinking day in and day out and
to have the resulting insights motivate
one's actions especially when those
actions are risky deviations from the
norm but if anyone can do this we can
so we wouldn't be here we wouldn't be us
without the people who supported and
nurtured us as well as the people who
tried to pull us down but actually
catapult catapulted us to success so I'm
going to go thank my high school for
kicking me out and then thank my friends
family and professors while we throw
back a lot of whiskey I encourage you to
handle yourself in similar ways
celebrate who you are and what you have
done but do it with some of the people
who are responsible for your being who
you are and accomplishing what you have
done congratulations and good luck out
there